I can tell you the first time I came
here to apply for a job I felt like in a
James Bond movie I saw this whole
apparatus was like whoa what is this I
think humans always adapt to stop so
when you come here every day at some
point you don't perceive it as being so
amazing anymore but of course then
people come and tell you and then you're
reminded and this is a really great
working environment the question is
always how do you trick people into
believing that they're actually in the
car or in the plane so of course we
cannot replicate the high accelerations
you feel in a car for a long time maybe
we could go along the strike for eight
meters but then the track runs also we
cannot simulate more forward
acceleration then we have to start doing
tricks and therefore you combine the
physical motion with an intelligent
visual stimulus and your brain has to
interpret all these signals and then
come to a coherent percept and that's
what we are investigating you how to
create a coherent percept that tricks
you into believing that you actually are
in a car or in a plane so if several
safety mechanisms here so we've written
custom software here at the Institute so
we have a whole robotics group that has
been working for some years on that and
Road control algorithms and so what we
can do is we either give some motions
which are predetermined so we know
before and what the robot will do or we
have the so called closed-loop
trajectories where we actually put the
control devices like a joystick or
steering wheel inside yeah yeah we have
a tracking system this is a bit like
something like a Kinect so all its
supposed to connect this depth camera
right and this is a optical track up so
I can show you on the so you have
markers like these these infrared
markers and this is now the oculus rift
head mounted display and then these
markers are tracked by the tracking
system down here and then once you move
your head it will track where you
actually are in space and how you are
oriented and then it updates the image
the visual image that you will see does
that have any impact on the movement of
the robot in our case nose and all case
the robot motion is pre-programmed and
this is just for you looking around in
the virtual environment yeah but it
would be possible to me
you were doing oh yeah yeah for sure at
one point we had to Formula one
simulator where you're driving along
Monza because all our roboticists were
from Italy so they implemented a Ferrari
on one side so it's very nice because
then the robot actually reacts to what
you are doing and tries to mimic as best
as possibility motions so that you feel
like you're in a real race car for
example yeah so is everything there yeah
exactly so now they are calibrating it
with these high frequency motions that
we did we ran into some yeah issues that
we didn't have before because usually
we've done more low frequency stuff and
so now they are figuring out how to
optimize the simulator for these high
frequencies all those high frequencies
supposed to be replicas but for this
experiment we want to replicate
turbulence like you experience it in an
airplane and that usually is a high
frequency motion I mean you are lowered
once you experience it it starts shaking
around and we do this for like 10
seconds here to make you feel as if
you're on an airplane experiencing such
turbulences the idea is to get virtual
reality headsets into airplanes so that
while you're on an airplane you can wear
if you want to if you choose to do so
wear a head mount display and actually
try to forget about that you are in
airplane and rather feel like you're at
the beach or in the mountains on some
scenario it's open space where you can
actually relax you can maybe also forget
about the passengers next to you and
just get out of there may be stressful
environment of the airplane so this is
the airplane environment one for each
eye for your left and your right and
then you get a stereo view so they are
slightly offset so you can perceive that
the whole thing is in 3d so on the right
screen here that's the infrared camera
that's looking inside of the cabin so
right now there's no one sitting in here
then up here that's the control screen
for the robot so what you can see here
all these numbers are commands that are
sent to the robot and that they are
controlling the motion of the robot
takes about 40 milliseconds from when we
send it until the robot actually does
the motion that's where we program the
motions of the robot so once the motion
is programmed it's going to be sent to
this computer because this is the
computer in the end that is controlling
these are some more control screens that
are more low-level that implement all
the safety stuff if they run into limits
and yeah if you actually want to control
over to come back to the starting
position or drive to starting position
or
so that's the race car seat we're going
to race down you see that you are in an
airplane and at some point you do
transition to a beach scenario if you
don't like it maybe turn to control
space some people in front of them close
then at some point we want to test what
happens if turbulence comes in the
airplane so what we do during the real
experiment we also take physiological
measures sub measure your heart rate and
still conduct what does they do to you
when you still believe that you are at
the beach or when you forget about the
beach think about the airplane again if
you shake your head around yeah you
likely to get sick so just move it
slowly over the ocean these head mounted
displays are becoming rather cheap now
and affordable so the one that you have
been wearing before is the prototype
that they are selling for three hundred
US dollars at the moment okay then we
give you an image again and then it
stops
so then you get the virtual environment
at the beach you can look around you can
see your body you can see the waves at
the ocean you can see some palm trees
and then at some point we want to test
what happens if turbulence comes in the
airplane imagine you're sitting in the
airplane you're burying this
head-mounted display you think you're at
the beach but at some point the airplane
starts shaking and now now it started to
shake of it might actually be relaxing
for you that you can think okay I am now
at the beach there's also my magic
carpet shaking a bit and maybe just some
strong wind but it's all good and I'm
more relaxed and I forget about the
turbulence so that's the type of
research question that we're looking at
that also has stereo projection
capabilities so you have two projectors
so if you don't want to use the
head-mounted display as you adjust it
you can have two projectors behind you
which are projecting on this curved
screen in front so you can just use the
whole cabin as a projection screen and
get I think hundred 60 degree view also
so it's very immersive so then you can
wear stereo glasses as you get in the
cinema and get also nice 3d images
already almost everyone has a smartphone
so maybe in the future everyone could
just take his own smartphone and then
you put it into a certain plastic frame
with two lenses and then you can look at
your smartphone use your smartphone as
the display and also as the sensors for
tracking your head motions you download
an app that will transport you to the
beach so basically you have your own
virtual reality headset always in your
pocket already
so these are motions that we run every
morning to test if everything is working
correctly this simulator costs around a
quarter million which is comparably
cheap to other simulators of that size
of these motion capabilities so we're
having it since several years at the
Institute and it's been used for lots of
project usually you have small platforms
with hydraulic legs and these costs may
be in the order of 50,000 but they are
much more restricted in their motion
range and then usually you go to very
big simulators which cost millions and
we are with the quarter million we are
in the middle range which I think still
gives us a really nice motion range for
it yeah does he ever go wrong like every
technical device of course we sometimes
run into problems that is more often
caused also by our faults right so we're
humans we make faults and programming it
but of course there's a lot of safety
stuff behind it so nothing can seriously
go wrong the only thing that happens is
usually that it doesn't move in the way
we want and then it stops right but it
never moves in a crazy way that we did
not foresee right so the only thing that
goes wrong is that it stops and doesn't
move I mean they use these robots of
course they use them for serious
applications in industry mostly I think
for car manufacturing so taking parts
and wedding stuff and Porsche or Daimler
yeah they have these robots if the only
pink one yeah you can walk around the
chair you can look underneath you don't
need to teach anyone how to use the
system in that way they put these
glasses on and they walk around what the
about or available but not as nice